so many new ideas were birthed during
the pandemic and one is a new concept
for a gym bianca holmen is live at
distant fitness lv with their new
approach to staying healthy i have a
feeling it's
keeping arms length and what else is
going on at that gym bianca
yes keeping arms length having that
private experience that's what's
happening here at distant fitness and i
understand you all just opened up kelsey
yeah so we've been open for a couple
weeks
we really just wanted to give our
clients a very comfortable and safe and
clean environment
it's for
personal trainers beginners pro athletes
we believe that anyone can really
benefit from what we're doing here at
this fitness yeah so you all have about
five different kind of fitness rooms we
got one right over here we got all the
equipment so like you said is it do can
people come in here individually can
they come in here with a small group
sure yes so they can come alone and we
offer up to four people in the studio so
whether you want to be alone or just
with your friends you can do that here
and i understand no with you all with
all the owners together you all have
like a nice variety of experiences i
mean you yourself you're an athlete yes
so i compete in power lifting i actually
hold the nevada state records for
squad bench and lift in my weight class
you're like don't let my height fool you
exactly yeah so we um many people have
like different training styles
we our equipment can cater to so many
different types of training wow power
lifting she's gonna have to show me how
much she can lift oh my goodness i need
to learn some tips for my little workout
session on this afternoon but thanks for
chatting with us we're going to learn
more we're going to take you inside some
of their studios down the hall there
coming up in the next half hour we're
going to send it back to you guys in the
studio all right thank you bianca